wow let's see
it recognizes me even with this fancy
mic on so
windows hello yay
doesn't it or did it just like turn off
it what no it didn't it wants a pin at
least it's not showing you my pin there
we go okay
this is my intro slide
my name is
mas torgersen or mas torsen
or
something like that my
norwegian friends out there are going to
kill me
um
they're going to take a blue sharpie to
that one after um
so i i work on the c sharp language
every day for microsoft um
it's a great job i wish you could all
have it but it's mine
so and i've done that for a very long
time and so that means i remember things
that nobody else remembers
uh almost except for anas anders as we
call him um who who was there from the
beginning i was not i i was a latecomer
i was i've only been there for 17 years
but it is an old language
we are now working on c sharp 11
and there's a whole nother talk about c
sharp 11 a little later today
um so i
i decided i want to talk about c sharp 1
through 10 today
um it's uh from the angle of how has
functional programming influenced
c-sharp over the years and i'm i'm
hoping that's interesting to you
otherwise that's a lot of people i'll be
disappointing today because it's a very
full room i don't know how many are out
there but um
you can still run without me noticing
unlike these people in here um so uh
yeah i think it's interesting because c
sharp started out as a fairly typical of
its age
fairly
uh straightforward object-oriented
imperative programming language that was
how it started
they didn't kind of just pull that out
of the blue of course there were other
languages around at the time that were
similar
that c sharp might happen to look a
little like
oh by accident
but
that was sort of like the the game of
the day so c-sharp was typical of the
day
and kind of pretty much took almost all
the functional things in along the way
as they became relevant to how we do
programming so um so i'm going to go
through that same evolution essentially
today and and point out some of the
different ways to try i'll try to make
some general points about programming
language paradigms and so on along the
way
um but it's all going to be a little bit
i'm going to do it all in visual studio
i'm just going to code along and so and
i and i forgot to print out my you know
my demo notes so uh so i might go astray
or it might like it'll be a little bit
of a one-off um we do have an hour
uh which means that um
there's time for a few questions along
the way not like a million but
i don't want you to say oh i want to ask
a question about that when he's done
talking
because by then the code will look
different nobody will remember what i
was talking about so if you have a
question
raise your hand and ask it and i'll try
to keep us on track and hopefully i'll
succeed and that might mean that i will
have to be a little rude and say sorry
no more questions come back after um so
just don't don't be offended when i get
to there but until then please um
please just um raise a question and ask
um
so with that
um without much further ado let's start
out with the c-sharp one and and just
kind of
for those of us who
were around
remind ourselves of the
the state of the you know the state of
the art of programming at least in the
industrial space in uh around the year
2000
and for those of you who weren't around
you know you can just go
thank god i wasn't around
um
i mean you're probably around most of
you but you maybe you were like still
doing legos or aren't we all really but
you know
so um
[Music]
what i have here is a fairly simple
it's a c-sharp one program i'm cheating
a little bit because
um when it comes to features that aren't
part of this talk that aren't functional
i'm just going to use them a little bit
anyway for instance my code is not in a
main method you don't need to do that
anymore in c sharp and if better fits
better on a screen if i don't so i'm not
going to like stick religiously to
only c 1 features
but in terms of functionality i am
so
um one thing to
so
talking about functional c sharp started
out with just a tiny little hint of
um a tiny little concession to
functional programming languages
compared to other languages at the time
and uh with something that they slash we
call delegates
which is sort of kind of like a function
type um they were actually part of some
of the
um
they were the need for delegates was
part of the reason why we couldn't do
some other programming languages and got
dragged into court and stuff
um so the so ceo back then already had
like a notion of a function
called delegate and those are still the
ones that we use for function types
they're flawed in various ways but
uh you know once you've got something
throughout the whole
core libraries and so on you don't go on
and change it so delegate types were
function types it's like you know this
is the type of a function that takes an
end and returns a bool and we it's a
name type like a class it is in fact a
class
and we call it predicate and now we can
use it as a function type
so
i can have a method here or function
that takes um takes a predicate
and it can call the predicate
as the you know according to the
function type but and when i want to
pass an argument to it
well we don't have anything like lambdas
yet that we're going to get to that we
don't have like anonymous functions of
any kind but we do have we but you can
sort of just mention a function that
happens to have the right
signature like gr greater than five
hang on a second
is it going to be like this all the way
like how many how many typos are we
going to have in here there we go
i did get the wordle this morning so i'm
not like totally
um there we go um
so um
so you kind of have to declare a
function then pass it you have to
declare the function type then use it
like it's all very nominal and
declarative at this point
but it gets the job done like you pass
the predicate in of course um
there's no such thing as generics yet
they're the first thing we're going to
learn from functional programming
language in a minute so you know
this was the name of the game right you
you uh
in order to filter this i need to gather
up the results
the only like i really wanted to return
an array because that's the only generic
type i have it's the only type that
actually has an element type so that's
so you kind of and you kind of encourage
to trade in arrays horrible as that is
because otherwise you have no type
safety but we do have other collections
they just all over object
so
and and i need to create one of those to
gather up my elements because i don't
know how many are going to succeed yet i
don't know what size of the array to
allocate first i gather them up then you
know i know how many i have then i can
allocate an array that's strongly typed
to end
then i have to stick all the elements
that i found into the array
and as i'm doing so i have to cast them
to end because i know their audience but
the compiler has no idea it's like you
stuck you get you give me a bunch of
stuff you're taking them out all i can
see is object
um so you know that you die a little
inside every time you have to cast
things coming out of collections do how
many people in here remember that from
like either sharp or some other like
java or yeah ouch yeah
um
so
what i think what we very quickly felt
all of us was
um
and with c-sharp it was already like
coming to version two which we're coming
to version two now um
we felt like okay this is not
this is not like a satisfactory state of
affairs
it's not the abstraction capabilities
aren't good enough here
some other languages that had been
around for longer it took them a little
longer to get to that point so it ended
up that for instance java and c-sharp
got generics which is where we're coming
to now at around the same time and i was
actually back then i was on the other
side of the fence helping out with
generics in java so i i saw it from the
other side
i still think microsoft and c-sharp did
it better um
so um it and this really comes down to
sort of one of the fundamental
differences between functional and
object-oriented programming it
you know in in classic imperative
programming there really is no
polymorphism like there's no way that
you can write code
that applies to more than one type
objective programming and functional
programming to a large degree are two
different answers at least when they're
typed they're two different answers to
how do you get polymorphism how do you
write code that works for more than one
kind of thing in object-oriented
programming we went with what's often
called subtype polymorphism which means
everything is a subtype of something
that's a subtype of something that all
you know all goes back up to object so
that's what we're seeing here now you
can write a collection like arraylist
here that can contain anything
so this polymorphism that sent sense and
the great thing about uh subtitle morphs
polymorphism is it's very easy to have
heterogeneous collections for instance
you can put like all kinds of things in
the same collection
as opposed to functional programming
they went with what's called parametric
polymorphism where
you have you have an extra type
parameter on things
that
that
you know sort of like a placeholder for
one type
so you don't get to mix and match the
types inside you get to say that this is
one type that i'm going to give you
later and then it'll work for that type
only but it's still portomorphic because
you can give different type arguments in
different places
and that has the benefit that you can
because that type parameter has a name
you can have things sync up so that they
the same type name the same type
parameter appears in multiple places and
you can sort of say well the same
whatever it is the same kind of thing
that comes in is the kind of thing that
comes out for instance which is exactly
what we need here right we need a
collection for instance that has
the same stuff coming in that's coming
out
um into generics
which is parametric polymorphism
most objective programming languages
with types at this point say okay let's
embrace that too so we have both kinds
in the language
so that's sort of one of the first
big imports from the functional space so
let's let's do that
now
let's see where do we start
um
now we can have well instead of
arraylist here we could we could now use
the new fancy generic collections that
we have i'm i
i'm cheating and having the imports in
another file or the using so you don't
have to to bother with that so we can
say list event here instead
is a new list of ant
and now
as i'm gathering things up it should be
graying out this i know that my um
uh my destination here is uh is actually
a list event and not just a list of
whatever and so i can i can now get rid
of this cast of death okay
back in business somebody wrote a
generic collection for us we can use it
but of course now
there are other i can i can write
generic things too maybe i'm maybe i
want my
predicate type to be more general or
maybe i don't actually want to write new
delegate types for everything all the
time
so maybe we could say predicate of t
and have it work for all t's and not
just for ants it still returns bull but
i can i now have a generic predicate
type and i can then here say well it's
actually here it's a predicate event
that i want and boom things don't work
or we can we could actually go a step
further and say well filtering isn't
really particularly about ins is it
and now we can write our own generic
function a method
that is a filter of t and now we get to
say t up t in all the places
it's actually a predicate of t coming in
and and an array of t and i'm returning
an array of t
and in all the other places where it
says int except one so you have to be a
little careful you know here here
here
where else
the end result of course
and
you know so now i've completely
generified the thing and this is the end
i shouldn't replace because that's the
counter for the uh you know filling out
the array so that
um so that's why i didn't just do a
search replace here um so there we go
now we all of a sudden we generified a
thing it's fully strongly typed
as if it was for a specific type but now
you can apply it everywhere and the full
like generic generification is a strong
strong tool um
and
um
it the
there were some like
choices
made in the different languages at the
time that that actually were imbued with
destiny even much more than we realized
at the time in java uh we on the i was
over here in the java side sorry camera
person um
we we were um
we we decided we couldn't change the jvm
the runtime under java because it was um
you know too entrenched and how you
couldn't control like what but java
runtime they had out there so so all the
generics in java was done in the
compiler by erasure which means you know
there wasn't any generics at runtime it
was just there in the code
for as much type checking as you could
get but that meant that there were some
things like reflection and so on that
didn't embrace it and there were certain
certain holes in the experience
essentially
and whereas in in.net and nc sharp we
went all out and said yes generics goes
into the runtime
and uh is shared across all the
languages at target.net and it's a real
runtime thing question
so to repeat the question for the for
the mic when did we know that we wanted
generics in c sharp
so
i wasn't there but i kind of was because
in 99 i was an intern
i was doing my phd i was an intern at
microsoft research cambridge which is
where don simons if anybody's heard of
him the father of f sharp
and there were a bunch of language
people there so i got actually to be
privy to decisions that were secret for
a number of years and i was under nda
until until things came out and they
were already talking about
net they weren't calling it that at the
time and they were already talking about
generics for it and decisions were made
that it would take too long
to make it work right
um and we should have a version without
it first so yeah
that
i think that that answers your question
precisely so it was always felt that
that we're gonna we're gonna need to do
this
and indeed generics was was the
pretty much the almost the only and and
on last thing
the language feature that was added to
the runtime for a very long time because
after that the net became popular it was
windows component and so we had the same
problem as java as the one causing java
to not do it in the runtime which was
too many people have it installed we
don't know which version of windows they
have we have no way of
you know making sure that they have the
right runtime features that we're
compiling for so we stopped doing
language features in the runtime after
that for a very very long time now we're
doing it again
and we might get to one at the end so
that's generics um
and
um
let's see if i can
get back on track here so um
it's well that's not generic in
that that's not all there is to say
about generics because once you get
these like
very lovely um
generic
collections for instance they can have
smarter
they can have smarter types smarter
methods as well they can have generic
methods so instead of
instead of like doing this building this
result array myself i could just
actually take that dst
thing and just call two array on it
because now it knows its element type
and you can build an array of the right
of the right type and namely t
um you also notice
um
so which means i can i can delete these
two lines of code i don't need that
anymore
um so many more utilities now strongly
type utilities become available
and
one last thing to notice is that when
i'm calling the generic method here i'm
not passing a type argument
you need to pass a type argument to to
the um to generic types but not your
generic methods and that again is a
thing that type inference is something
that we start stealing from functional
programming languages we can't do as
much type inference in optic jointer
programming languages as you can in a
functional language because of the
subtype polymorphism it means that you
can't actually you can there are many
places where you can't know the exact
type where you could if you didn't have
subtype polymorphism so we can't go all
out on on type inference which is
probably all the same because it's
confusing to a lot of people and it's a
quiet taste so so we kind of we we have
to strike a balance there but it
certainly makes sense here
um
so with that lovely generics um
we
um
we can also get out of this addiction to
to arrays as the um that's kind of like
the um the the currency of collections
being passed around because arrays are
you know they're very low level
fixed size
they expose too much they're unsafe in
various ways because you pass your array
to someone and they they're messing with
it while you're watching it somewhere
else and you know that's just you know
nasty so we can start having other uh
interfaces for instance that are that
are more suitable so enumerable of t
is a good one
i can return a number of t as well here
and
and i don't even have to say two array i
can but i don't have to say two array
because of course a list of t is also an
inaudible so you know things get simpler
um
we could do one better actually um
we
we also oh
oh
well it's because i'm saying in the ray
here yeah yeah i have to
i have to just make all the changes okay
so
oh int thank you
say are you developers or something it's
like it's like you it's like you
understand what i'm saying
hey i also debugged something once you
know it's fun
so um
so um
so so far so good we
one thing we actually decided was now we
have a number of t it's like a very in
abstraction over just sequences of data
we're going to meet this a lot more in c
sharp three but already in c sharp two
we were like actually the compiler could
help a lot with this kind of work here
um of producing enumerables because they
don't have to be produced eagerly they
don't have to have all the elements
precomputed they can actually sort of be
lazy and compute things along the way
and we can build a language feature to
help with that and that's what we call
iterators in c sharp they're called
generators in some other languages
which is essentially you write a
function and then once in a while you
say oh here's another element for the
result and then you compute some more
and then or here's another element for
the result and it actually gets executed
lazily up to every every one of those
points you you just pause and and give
the result back and then the next time
the consumer asks for a result they come
you execute some more so that's
iterators into sharp that means we don't
even need like an accumulator
we can just say if that thing
you know just
yield return
the value i'm not
super excited about the syntax we chose
there i will just say i was not around
um
we liked keywords a lot still back then
we kind of do still a little bit
and now i'm
you know
that's it
that's the filter method you know you
you use you cycle through you yield
return something if you decide that they
let me do that and that's it right so
boom very nice
also in c sharp 2 we're like hey we've
heard about lambda expressions
let's do
not that
something similar let's have anonymous
functions why do you have to declare all
the functions that you want to pass
that's just like a pain
let's get rid of all these declarations
and stuff so instead of saying greater
than five here what if i could just
write the function with the body and
everything in place here so we come up
with an elegant syntax saying delegate
delegate all the crap
there we go
beautiful right
it's well we can laugh now but you know
it's certainly an improvement now
now um you know i'm free to just come up
with functionality and pass it along and
of course the compiler generates
something under the hood that's similar
to before but hey all languages do do it
like that pretty much so so great
um our first take on anonymous functions
now c sharp three
now we have big ambitions this
functional thing has really gotten into
our blood and this is where i'm starting
to be around so i've witnessed more of
this firsthand so in c sharp three we
we want to we want to solve
querying once and for all
the functional languages can do it we
can do it too so we want to mainstream
functional approaches to solving
querying
let's do that
and we have i mean filter is a is a
great example like it's it's a it's a
function that does querying
uh a one one aspect of querying we kind
of have the generics in place to do this
um
why don't we why don't we actually
um declare an even more general library
of function types and then we also
declare a library of of um
querying methods
and and get all that stuff working
um
so we
um
so instead of just having predicate of t
we we create a family families have
functions called called func and action
func for the ones that return stuff um
so funk of
t1 comma t result or something like that
um that take a t and return a t result
so that's what the funcs look like take
a t1 here and we just declare them in
the core library so i don't even have to
do it here they're available to everyone
who wants to be a little bit functional
and uh and we can just uh here actually
it doesn't predicate us also actually in
the core libraries from from back
back way way back when so it doesn't
give me a red squiggle here but let's
say funk of
t comma bool instead
to describe the function we're passing
in here um
and then
instead of me writing the the
filter method um
uh as kind of a one thing that you
quickly find out when you want to you
want to query things is hey i want to i
want to filter some more for instance i
want to call query methods on top of
query methods so i could call filter
twice you know i could say filter
on the result of the first filter
comma
you know some other
delegate
thing
and
you know it quickly becomes long
um i should probably done lambda at
first shouldn't i
i'm going to be doing more typing
okay
hold that thought let me do let me
switch to lambdas quickly
we get we get better syntax
that's actual lambdas
you can do this it's a little shorter or
we have so there's still a like a
statement body there or we can actually
do um
just an extra single expression and now
it starts it starts being a little
expression oriented like the like the
functional languages that's kind of kind
of exciting but but we still have the
problem now if i want to filter that one
some more i can say int y
arrow something stuff um oh it needs to
be in parens here
um
actually does it you know lambda you can
act you don't actually have to say the
type if it's given from the from context
you don't have to say it that's kind of
cool
um
but
so why i want to get the ones that are
even
stupid example but just you know
equals zero
you know i can i can compose my
my query methods but it sucks right i'm
composing sort of
inside out like this first stuff is in
the middle and then i'm slapping stuff
on both sides of it and it's completely
unreadable
well what do the functional people do
when they i mean they doing this stuff
how do they do it well they have
pipelining operators you can call
functions like this but you can also
pipeline so in a functional language
what you would do is you would start out
with the array
on the left side and then you would um
so let me let me do some horrendous uh
doctoring here you start out with the
array you would have some kind of
pipeline operator which we don't have in
c sharp and you pass it in to filter
filtering the first thing
uh and that that's just the implicit
first argument for it there and then
you'd pipe that into
filtering the second thing
and now you have things in the right
order they're sort of cascading
beautifully
in the order that you're doing them it's
kind of fluent man as we said so
um
so that's that's
can we do something like that into
sharpening that's where extension we
come up with extension methods which
is essentially just to solve this little
problem in the beginning they turn out
to be like extremely useful in extremely
many scenarios we're still being
inspired by them and we want to do more
with them um where what you're saying is
we're just
what if you just pretend that the static
method or this function is actually like
a
an and um
it's a i can't do it with a
um
i can't do it with just this uh this
method here because it's not actually
um it's not declared in a proper space
but we can do the syntax is like this uh
we just pretend it's an instance method
on the first the first argument and now
i can go and add method what looks like
instance methods to other people's types
and that kind of gives you that flow
so luckily i don't have to like go and
do it properly here because it turns out
that method just like filter is being
added to the libraries at the same time
and now we can just do the where stuff
so we can get rid of our own filter
method and use
the one that's part of the query library
that we are now providing
okay
so
we can break it up a little here and now
it starts to kind of look decent right
now we have a select for projecting
because why would we call it project
we have um
various methods i'll tell you why we
call it select that's because another
place where you do querying is
is in um you know sql which is also kind
of functional right it's
it's also just i mean you can they're
aspects of sql where you can mutate
stuff and actually get things into the
database but the actual querying is
functional too and so we want to provide
syntactic sugar for for querying on top
of methods like this where you can say
from
[Music]
from
value
in i just call them x i like x from x in
array
where
the keyword
where
x is greater than 5
and where something else
where
y
let's call it x again then because we
are now using the same variable name all
the way down
select something
so we now have query syntax select
you know maybe just x
so and and the point here is it looks
like sql is a little different because
in sql they start with a select clause
which means we don't like that in
programming languages because they start
out by describing the result and what
you want is to start out by
describing
the where the the source like where do
things come from so you can get types
going and have your tooling kind of help
you out as you type the code from one
end to another so we want to start with
the array figure out what this type is
get completion in our in our clauses uh
and so on so that's that's a programming
proper programming language way of doing
it sorry sql folks but you you got it
wrong and you didn't think about id you
didn't think about ides back in 1970
when i was
ide focused uh language design that's
that's the way that's why we have
typescript
so um
so great but now that actually just
queries my in-memory data like wouldn't
it be cool if i could actually use the
same syntax and
both the syntactic sugar and actually
also the method called syntax to query
actual sql databases that and with this
you know no difference in syntax and
that's where we get to another
functional uh yet another functional uh
loan which is um
code quotations so
uh in lisp for instance it's all based
around the fact that code is data like
code and data are no different and you
can always easily take code and
represent it as a data structure
well that's kind of cool because then
you can do meta programming you can take
that data structure and do stuff with it
and one of the things you could do with
a data structure representing a query is
you can translate it to sql and send it
to a sql database and have it run a sql
and have the result come back and then
you do a little translating back and now
you have an object oriented
an object relational model
so if we take that
let's
just say var here more type inference if
we take that array and say
um is it too queryable or ask variable
listening squarable
there you go and say as querable
i'm sort of cheating a little i'm
representing it as
uh now acquirable is like a
representative of some other data source
that uses quote quotation in order to
um
to
do the querying
um so when i do that
what changes as well not much you know
it's i get an iquerable back instead
whoop to do but if we go and um and look
at um if you go and look at that query
um
query dot
you can see that it has something inside
called an expression and that expression
in fact represents
the
the data structure of all this query
okay so we're building up instead of
having the code just code that we can
run instead we build up a data structure
with exactly the same syntax um and now
querying of in-memory data and occurring
of of um
of sql databases looks the same just
like
you can do in
in many functional languages that have
code quotation so yet another loan there
and i just i just cheated a little bit
and showed you var as well
which is like the last um
one more concession to type inference
like very simple one it's like why do i
have to say the types all the time it's
really bothersome to have to say int can
you let me say a three-letter keyword
instead
obviously that's not the best example
this is the best example right i don't
wanna have to write iquerable of blah
blah blah i wanna
i want to just say hey the thing you
know give me the thing
if it's clear from context that it's
what kind of thing it roughly is you
know who cares so
so that's uh that's functional up until
c sharp three it's a good a good time to
ask for questions we're about halfway
through the story and about halfway
through the hour so still on track
anything any thoughts coming up here
questions meta questions
programming questions meta programming
questions yes
what made me decide
anders heilsberg made me decide
um
it okay a
short
short version of the story
i was i was a professor
i wasn't liking it too much
i was collaborating with the java team
at sun microsystems then had a great
time doing
real world
you know
you know
real world language design for real
customers
they got to do it all day i got to do it
like whenever i could get away from
teaching and stuff and i just like well
i have a great time when i'm working
with them
and they make twice as much money as me
at least i think um so it's like maybe
i'm not in the right career here and as
i was thinking that there was a
conference in oahu's
anders was there talking about how they
were going to do generics in c sharp i
was there talking about how we were
going to do generics in java
you know
the rest is history
he he had money i didn't so he hired
he hired me not the other way around um
actually also i liked how he talked
about language design whenev when i was
involved in java language design it was
always like there was always a lot of
stop energies like we can't do this
because and we can't do this because and
he had a bunch of can-do attitude
you know
a small example the now the the generic
method is gone from the screen here but
in java they said oh we can't put the
type parameter for generic methods after
the parameters because that might be a
syntactic ambiguity in rare cases
and in c sharp when he showed examples
that would also be a syntactic ambiguity
in rare cases in c sharp because syntax
is a little bit alike um but they just
put it there anyway and i asked him
after like how how do you do that he's
like ah we just do some we just do some
tricks in the compiler it's not like lr1
or whatever we it's fine we figure it
out and you know and and who cares about
those rare cases you know we we come up
with a rule that works 97 of the time if
you run into it and does the right thing
mostly and and we're good there was
always like we can probably solve that
problem attitude and that spoke to me in
a way and that's
still the case and i that's still why i
love being there so oh
thanks for that question now i'm going
to have a tear in my eye for the rest of
the day
anything else
i want to hear about my childhood
why oh great question so why
why are
the delegate types that
have the same shape like the same
signature why why aren't they
interchangeable
um
so there's so there used to be predicate
of t and then then it turned into we
started using funk of
t kamabul
and they're not actually interchangeable
you can pass the same lambdas to them
but you can't pat you can't assign one
to the other they're not structurally
equivalent
so and that comes back to
you know i kind of hinted that i'm not a
super fan of delegates
um and one of the problems with them is
that they're a nominal type they have a
declaration and just like classes that
look the same you can't take an object
of a class and duct type it to another
class that happens to be the same
it's all based on the declarations
it's very very nominal as we say and the
same is true for
for the
the delegate types there are actually
classes and they are nominally tight
now in visual basic for instance
vb.net
they paper over this
by
inserting implicit like
wrapper
functions to translate from one to
another so there you get the great
experience of it all just assigns to
each other it looks extremely structural
but the problem is it isn't like it
comes with a cost like you're rapping
more and more if you keep if you if you
keep passing back and forth you get like
layers and layers of oh here's a
predicate of a funk of a predicate of
you know all the way so um
uh so we don't let you we don't let you
go down that rabbit hole in c sharp um
we think about it sometimes and we also
think about well could we just do better
function types
but then you have a library
that is gigantic and that is using
delegates everywhere and you look at
that and you go hmm
i wonder how we could do this and not
mess up a million customers
you know or you know we choose not to
roll it out in our big library and just
make it you know an option for new code
and then
it doesn't really there's no bang there
right you know you don't get enough
value so
that's a tough problem that you know the
problem of legacy code and the problem
of of compatibility uh shoots down a lot
of good feature ideas and um
and uh we haven't found a way around
this one we we are it's one of several
interestingly uh functional functionally
inspired topics that we'll be discussing
this summer we're having sort of a
series of summer camps on the team where
we'll discuss topics that are normally
out of bounds because we don't know how
to deal with them
and this is one of them
so maybe one day we'll figure out a way
to make that good
yeah so the question is um is the
um it's a sequel style syntax still in
in broad use um
and and it's true it does feel very
different from the rest of the language
it's yeah it's just it's like you enter
another world
um
yeah we have to maintain compatibility
with it but also furthermore i think it
is still it is still used a bit like a
bunch
not more than a bit actually a bunch of
people actually do prefer the method
called syntax even when they are using
the query methods
i find that
if i have to do
more than one from
from x in blah from y in
x dot or something like that then
writing the corresponding query with
method calls becomes um
becomes mind-blowingly hard and you have
to use select many and select many is
mind-blowing and so
uh i always if i have to if i have to
like do more than one from if i have to
like dig into data with froms i i switch
to career syntax and let the compiler
figure it out for me because i my brain
can't handle it it's all actually
it's all down to moan ads so how many
people here know about monads
yes that's more than i would have
expected actually
it's this concept that is super central
to a bunch of functional type functional
programming
and nobody understands it a bunch of
people claim that they do but they're
actually just
you know it's it's a collective kind of
like it's it's a hoax um they don't
not for long anyway i've i've understood
it many times and then you know the next
day i was like what was it again so
maybe i was just streaming it it made it
totally makes sense at the time but
query query expressions
they are a monad they're a language
support for a monad and um
and when you use more than one from that
is where you get into monetic territory
where the the select many is the thing
that makes them makes them a moan ad and
that's that's exactly why it gets
mind-blowing to do it directly it's
because it's monad and you want syntax
for that but other than that people have
different styles there are also people
who work on low level code they'll be
like this is way too inefficient um it
does you there's all this laziness right
that the iterators are generating things
along the way which means you have all
this like
you have a bunch of structure you have
all these it calls through interfaces
and so on and so if you're doing
performance intensive code one of the
things that people look for in code
reviews is oh
oh you have a query there well fix that
you know go back to
ugly array-based stuff because then it's
going to be faster
so
i i will say that entity framework
alive and kicking
offers up
you know a query provider implementation
and people do use that and they do use
the qree syntax when they're interacting
with that because it is a database
technology outside of that maybe not so
much
okay
all right uh one more
time
that's true yes
so that's a great question because um
and we might touch on it a little bit
later um
so let me repeat again um the uh
one thing you can do in the career
syntax is you can use let to actually
introduce more temporary variables
inside of the query i haven't done it in
many years actually let's see if we can
do that let y
equal x times two or something like that
yeah it worked at least it compiles so
so now so now the rest of the query has
access to x and y
um
and um
and that's really useful because you
have sort of like variable declaration
inside of an expression rather than as a
separate statement and that has
continued to doggers that statement
based
um
approach to variable declarations has
continued to dog us and in later
versions of c sharp there are more and
more places where you can now declare
variables inside of um
inside of an expression we haven't done
it completely generally we had a
proposal for it but we never went that
far but there are many situations now
where you can declare an inline variable
particularly in pattern matching which
we're going to get to soon so that even
provides like a i could segue for that
um
so
you know at the and another like big
difference is
functional languages tend to be very
expression based typically a function
doesn't have side effects right in the
pure uh function uh functional uh sense
so you don't really need statements you
just need an expression saying what the
whole thing is you know and then you
stick it together you put sub
expressions inside and it's all
expression based and so you need things
like variable declaration to be
expression-based
and the more expression-based the more
we get inspired by that in c-sharp the
more of a shortcoming it becomes that
variable declaration isn't one of them
so great great point and this is a way
to sneak it in you can't do that with
method call syntax because it does
sneaky things under the hood it builds
little like tubal-like things to keep
track of all the variables under the
hood
okay
yep okay let's uh let's fast forward a
little bit then we did dynamic that was
certainly not very functional t-sharp
four c sharp five we did async which was
potentially very functional f sharp
already had a solution to async which
was also sort of magnetic
and which is beautiful
but is very ill-suited for a
predominantly
imperative language so we went in a
different direction with async and the
f-sharp and
the generally functional approach to
async is quite different from
from
the imperative approach that we use in
c-sharp essentially they use
an approach where they build up the
whole control flow of the async ahead of
time and then you kind of pull a handle
in and and it runs it's like you built
all the pipes and then you turn on the
water
um
and in uh and in our async we sort of
more like
um
laying out the pipes as the water is
coming it's uh we sometimes call it cold
and hot async like we work with tasks
which are which are uh that's our
currency and async which are things that
are already happening things that are
already concurrently operating and then
you can take a task and then you can say
well i'm ready for you are you ready for
me and get a result out of them so
that's all much more imperative fits
better with imperial workflow so there
we didn't go the functional way we don't
always do it
um in c sharp six
we started like getting interested in
the expression-based stuff again though
so i'm going to switch to a different a
different file here
um
so one thing that you know we really
like the expression bodies of lambdas
we're like why should only lambdas be
allowed to have expression bodies why
can't all our functions all our function
members have expression bodies and we're
like okay c sharp six we did kind of
half of them and in c7 we did the rest
so now
all function members in c sharp can have
expression bodies where you just put
that lambda arrow there the fat arrow as
we shouldn't call it
um
and um
and uh you get it you know you don't
have to say return if your only
statement is return something you know
cut the boiler plate
but it's just syntactic sugar right
um
so but coming to c sharp seven
uh we're starting to think about more
fundamental things again so not not so
much in the syntax
syntactic sugar you know as a feel kind
of
of layer but really like
oh oh
object oriented program is kind of
screwed in these new scenarios that are
becoming very predominant and
and um
and widespread
essentially
when it comes to cloud programming
history is on the side of functional
programming i'm sorry object-oriented
programming is not good for that if you
think about and that comes down to how
how you describe operations over
types of data
in
in both
object-oriented and functional
programming there are ways that you can
write functions so that they have
appropriate behavior for each shape of
data for each type but those ways are
very different they're like actually
i think probably if eric meyer was here
he would say that there's a duality like
they're completely like
um the opposite of each other um what we
what we do in in in classic object
programming we love encapsulation we
love saying the data is actually secret
i'm not even i'm not exposing it because
then i can change it whenever i like and
then i just offer up some functions and
i can have a class hierarchy with
virtual functions
that i can then describe for each type
of data what it does so so the super
like
idiotically simple example here is the
two string virtual method right where
i'm i'm
i am describing the string
representation of the object
as a
by overriding the virtual uh method
string
great you know that means that whenever
i
i write a new derived class from person
here or from object actually in this
case you know i can just override that
behavior
to suit whatever my shape is and
somebody else can call it on the base
class and not even know i exist but
still get the right behavior
um
excellent except
when you have a world where
data is long-lived in the cloud maybe or
in databases and whatnot and different
people are writing different
functionality over the same data models
well oops now it's not so good to
encapsulate those
those behaviors with the data model
right they you want to be independently
be able to express
behaviors over the data model um
that
that still depend on like it's still
type specific but that uh
the the original type knows nothing
about and that the different
domains of of behavior have no idea
about each other
so encapsulation is dead right you need
for those scenarios you need the data to
be public
and luckily we have you know auto
properties to make that easy
but you
and you need
the functions to work from the outside
but
in a c sharp six setting so let's let's
say we're still in six
doing something
let's say i wanna let's say i wanna
write the two string method
from the outside that's actually fairly
hard that's annoyingly clunky and and
that you get back to that dying inside
feeling
um so uh so but let's try to do it i'm
making you all die a little bit inside
i'm sorry we'll
we'll revive that part and there'll be
flowers and it'll be good uh in a minute
but you know um so let's say two string
string let's call it
let's call it something else to render
and
you take um
you take a person
it's not even generics involved here you
take a person p and then you want to
render it according to which kind of you
know which person
derived class it is
um so we could do that we can say you
know we have type testing in c sharp we
can say if p is a student and that's the
only derived class that i actually put
in here but you know imagine there are
dozens
um for each of those you say if p is
student then do at least we have
expression body members here no i can't
do that here
return
whatever the student does
okay i'm cheating a little using
interpolated strings here
return that
except of course um i have to
dot my way into that public data no
problem
but as i get to the student specific
property here oh oh you know i
i already i just asked but i already
forgot that it was a student so i don't
get to
oh
if only we were typescript you know
typescript it it has flow-based typing
you know a variable you know if you
figured out it wasn't something and then
this branch then then you know it'll
know you're something else and it's
beautiful but we can't that's that'll be
super breaking in c sharp and also their
compiler
is
uh you know just thank god that they
don't promise type safety let me just
put it like that so um
so that is kind of annoying what to do
well
you know in c sharp six your best option
is to you know cast
p to student knowing it will succeed
because you're smarter than the compiler
um
until you maintain your code a little
bit and somebody else takes over and
they they do a refactoring manually and
stuff blows up
um
but that we can do that and then el does
an else you know else return
that other stuff let's just get it in
there so we can um so we can mutate the
code a little bit um return that stuff
um and of course there would be else ifs
um for every other like derived class
here so here we here we get here we get
to do p this and p at that so far so
good but functional languages they do
this all the time
and it's interesting to note that
there's a fundamental difference in how
the um
how the um
you know what kind of what kind of
contract you have here when you use
object-oriented programming as i said
you can add a new class whenever you
want and you can just override that
virtual method and everyone's happy
right because the code and the class are
together if you add a new type
like in the in this functional setting
you you are explicitly in the function
you were mentioning all the different
shapes that you care about
um and if somebody adds another shape of
data and you you know your code is no
longer handling that so there's a
different you you can't
add new data with impunity but you can
add new functions with impunity which
you can't do in the in the in after
you're growing a world
you can't go without going back and
editing the original right you can't
independently add new functions in
opti-growing programming but you can add
new types in functional programming you
can't
uh you can't
independently add new types but you can
add new functions i said well this
really is a duality but they do the
other thing so well and what is it they
do well they do pattern matching so the
first step there is let's um
um
let's actually let you declare a
variable inside of this expression
you know like after this this expression
that's already that's actually let you
put a variable name and say okay i just
checked can i just get a name for that
can i get a receipt um and you and you
use that uh throughout here and that is
your p
typed a student uh with its own name and
now we can we can
you know we're not dying inside anymore
except if i can at least think what
oh no
um
what's that
yes it was the wrong parent no
yes thank you thank you
i'm code blind thank god i only have six
minutes left oh my god i only have six
minutes left
so so what we're getting into is pattern
matching and pattern matching is this
whole it's a whole new concept that
we're adding to c sharp at this point
but it's not new in the in global sense
it's a well throttled path in
in functional programming we just have
to adapt it to an object-oriented
context and and this is a pattern a
pattern is something that
that can either succeed or not when you
apply it to a value and if it succeeds
it can extract some extra information
and put it in variables for you that's
what a pattern is and we have a few
patterns from the beginning and c sharp
seven and then we start adding some more
along the way and we keep we're still
adding patterns to this date like c
sharp 11 has
list patterns which you will if you go
to the other talk you'll get to see
those um
but it's still like the the the shape of
the code like we solved the micro
problem but the larger problem of if you
know having a very imperative way of
checking that's also very like
um
uh kind of fraught with danger in terms
of maintenance and so on
what we want along with pattern matching
is we want
what functional programming
often calls matching pattern matching
we have a keyword already called switch
so we're using that one so let me go and
uh let me go and just you know do this
again um so
i'm gonna do it in a functional way
let's just we can
we can comment this out
so we're gonna do just an expression
body we're going to take the person
and we're going to switch on them
but not with an old-fashioned clunky
switch statement from c in the early 60s
that we have in c-sharp but with a
switch expression you know like the cool
kids so this expression body that's a
switch expression it's empty right now
uh that's actually okay but you get a
warning saying you're not handling all
the different kinds of input yeah okay
thank you
um so and now we can write patterns
directly here student s arrow
and now we can just put an expression
for the result
that you want in case it's it is a
student all right so i can i now have
like a a clean structure within which i
can just list comma separated patterns
and results
and i right now i only need the two
so we're going to take
we're going to just do this
and then
just quickly touch on the fact that
patterns can be
pattern matching is smarter right we saw
that it said that you were not handling
all the cases it still did that when we
only had the
when we only had the student but when i
do a catch-all which i can do with a
fancy modern discard um
then it says hey you're handling
everything you're good no more warning
well what if i go the other way like
let's just let's just swap the order of
these two they are in order then i
actually get an error saying hey you
handled you handled this case already so
so you can see how
maintenance of these things becomes much
not only is it clear to read but the
compiler is helping you much more keep
your logic straight so it's beautiful
and it's safe that sounds like
functional to me um
so uh
so you can do that but you know i'm
you're noticing i'm actually writing out
just the first letter of the first name
and in this case here well
actually what if what if the what if the
first name is empty i'm not going to
talk about null right now that's a whole
other talk but what if it's empty that's
kind of you know i should probably do
something else if it's empty so let's
um let's use just to show an example of
a recursive pattern i know now that it's
just a person but what if the first name
of that person
actually is an empty string
um i want to do something else then i
just want to write out the last name i
don't want to like do the whole
abbreviation thing
p last name
um or
you know i could actually
in so this is a property pattern i can
dig out specific properties inside of
the pattern and recursively apply a
pattern here i'm just applying the
pattern are you this constant but i
could also say last name
colon and then apply a var pattern which
always succeeds but which will give you
a name so that you let that's your
pattern let um it's the var pattern um
and um and then instead of saying peter
last name here i already dug out the
last name and i gave it a name so i can
just say l here so
and and these things compose you know if
i wanted the actual
uh if i wanted a new name for the the
person object itself i could put it here
uh let's call it p2 or whatever so so
patterns kind of compose and and over
time we've added more and more kinds of
them
that
essentially make them more and more
expressive and allow you to put more and
more of your logic
into patterns so that your
shape-dependent
code is now as beautiful or some would
say even more
i i i don't i'm not but um
you know it's a great beautiful first
class alternative to virtual methods
when you when describing the
functionality on the outside is what you
want to do you do pay something you pay
the fact that
you can't really nearly add new types
you pay the fact that your data has to
be public so that it can be operated on
from the outside so encapsulation's out
the window but you get this other beauty
so you know pick your poison depending
on the scenario now you have both
options in c sharp
and
i also wanted to mention immutability
but
i just did
we did work for immutability um first we
let you have uh auto properties without
setters but that wasn't so good for the
um for the object initializers now
there's a more um that now you have a
new kind of setter it's called an
emitter which is a setter that can only
be called from object initializes and
now so that means we made immutable
objects more first class you don't need
to initialize them with constructors you
can use object initializers for those as
well immutability is another functional
concept that we're we're starting to
support more
so um
i'm gonna stop here
um with in the c-sharp sevens
um
and if you wanna see some c-sharp 11
functional influence uh you know there's
another talk in just an hour and a half
or whatever and
for now thank you very much
[Applause]
you